jetzt auch noch mal zurück zum saarland
zur ersten landtagswahl des jahres um
diesem mega-event wirklich gerecht zu
werden haben wir diesmal gleich zwei
reporter losgeschickt fabian köster
leistet rau arbeiten mit der spd und
lutz van der horst der sich als der
dienst ältere den job aussuchen durfte
mischt sich unter enthemmte partypeople
bei der union
schadenfreude hat in der politik ja
eigentlich nichts zu suchen aber wie
froh ist man trotzdem dass der schulter
aktion die ersten risse bekommen
koalitionspartner aber wenn die kamera
gleich ausgeschlossen fühlt man sich an
so einem tag mich trotzdem dass das
saarland in frankreich geblieben wäre
einer wirklich nicht
kaum licht wir brauchen noch ein
bisschen freude für die kamera also
emotionen diese emotionen lassen heute
überall noch nicht nur grün sondern
emotionen heißt ja auch mal lachen
jubeln
doch langsam berg
tja die spd-generalsekretärin flieht vor
mir also die hat keine angst vor ihnen
bietet das thema war feige
vorwerk an palmsonntag mit jesus
christus auf dem esel in jerusalem ein
und die rosa lämmer haben ihn als könig
der juden gefeiert so was ist wie der
schuld letzte woche erklärt ak freitag
mit
das heißt sie wollen freut die
mannschaft von trainer ich will ihn
nicht treu auspeitschen nein mit
inhalten versucht martin schult ohne ihn
hat versucht bleibt der spd jetzt noch
diplomatin zurück hat sehr viele inhalte
100 mittags klinik kennen zum beispiel
zum beispiel dass er soziale
gerechtigkeit bereichen da muss ich
lachen gerade gerechtigkeit der arme aus
gouda warum hätten wir nicht gegönnt das
noch mal regiert warum nicht jetzt da
auch diese junge frau der noch eine
perspektive bieten muss der arme herr
saarland ist einfach egal eigentlich
dann auch im endeffekt egal wenn man mal
das große ganze geht also im endeffekt
da sieht man dass er die mädchen
vergreifen sich großen letzten wochen ja
ein mädchen gewünscht werde die mädchen
sind für viele mädchen man ja im
endeffekt ihr also zum beispiel am
freitag bei martin schulz auch noch da
und waren mädchen medien die
medienbrücke
da war natürlich auch französische
medien ganz klar immer mädchen medien
medien print medien medien
kramp-karrenbauer herzliches beileid das
war es mit der karriere in berlin
wir würden den saarland bleiben doch
glauben nein ich bin wahrscheinlich
wirklich weil man kann auch vom land aus
was mögen sie nicht an mir
ich mag sie aber ich habe keine lust am
reden als trauriges eines stoffes
tut mir leid mein beileid
auch richtig ok
ganz schön aber noch auf schönes leben
auch
nein